hallo ich meine lieben philips und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
kräftig ideen wo ich eure besten fünf
tradingideen die militärischen können
beantwortet und feuchten komme direkt
zur ersten sache und zwar weil mir die
erste sache zugesendet von ist gibt und
zwar schreibt er dass man ja einfach mal
ein ob sie die antwort machen könnte was
ganz normal betrachtet wie ein ganz
normales holzboot also beim holzbläser
werden fünf holz so zu sonnen kleinen
angeordnet mit dem holzboot kann man
dann über wasser fahren das obsidian
boot wird genauso gebaut allerdings
anstatt der holzplanken werden da
einfach ob sie die anklage genommen das
boot ist dementsprechend nicht holz
farben sondern lila und man kann damit
über lava fahren anstatt über wasser
also man ist damit quasi auch so ein
bisschen geschützt voll aber man kann
damit einfach über riesige lager sehen
im untergrund oder einfach auch in der
hülle es wäre extrem nah da wir durch
die hölle damit fahren hörte einfach
drüberfahren und das ist kräftig idee
nummer eins und dass wir auf jeden fall
richtig richtig cool wenn so was kommen
würde
die zweite sache wurde zugesendet von
zocker bruders und zwar meinen sie eine
apfelschorle wäre ganz geil das ganze
quartett man wie es jetzt eingeblendet
sieht und zwar oben drei äpfel in die
mitte vom crafting table ein wasser und
um das wasser herum quasi so drei zucker
ganz einfach apfelsaft besteht ja
einfach aus äpfel konzentraten abfüllung
ganz grob aus apfel und zucker und
wasser und das sap und ihr seht schon
habe ich wieder ein bisschen was
gepixelt da würde man dann einfach drei
apfelsäfte apfelsaft apfelsaft
apfelsäfte apfelsaft raus bekommen und
könnte die dann ganz einfach trinken und
ich habe auch schon oft gesagt ich
wünsche mir trinken in minecraft und das
war einfach richtig cool weil dieses
trinken würde dann quasi irgendwie so
zwei hunger balken auffüllen oder so und
man wird das dann einfach schlürfen und
wenn ich auf jeden fall ganz cool
die dritte sache wurde mir zugesandt von
shadow
und er meint es wäre ganz cool wenn man
sich bei stock kräften könnte gehstock
ich hab da mal ein bisschen weiter
gedacht und hab mir gedacht vielleicht
meint er trocken
jedenfalls würde man sich diesen
gehstock bzw bedrock so kraft indem man
einfach acht eisen blöcke ringsum
zusammen kreis an liegt also wird man
sich eine test machen und in die mitte
einfach einen obsidian bock also ganz
ganz feste blöcke und dann würde man
einen bottrop bekommen die man nicht
abbauen kann also irgendwie für survival
falls man sich irgendwie in den krieg
ins umfeld des haus bauen möchte was
komplett stabil gegenüber tnt ist und
alles mögliche kann man sich so ein
bettler kräften und das war sache nummer
drei und jetzt kommen wir zur sache
nummer vier danke an dich thomas lpx
meint das ist richtig richtig cool wenn
es andere kisten gelbe als um die
holzkisten also beispielsweise emine
steinke ist oder eine diamant ist oder
golden oder kohle oder kohle also
irgendwelche anderen kisten formen die
dann dementsprechend desto wertvoller
diese rohstoffe sind mit denen man die
kisten kräfte dementsprechend dann auch
mehr platz bieten ihr seht nämlich jetzt
gerade schon ein crafting rezept
eingeblendet von einer diamant kiste
beispielsweise da würde man dann einfach
diamanten nehmen die zu einer ganz
normalen kiste anordnen so wie man das
sonst mit holz machen würde und dann
würde man eine diamant kiste bekommen
diese diamant kiste würde dann
beispielsweise irgendwie dreimal so viel
platz liefern wie ein ganz normaler
holzkiste dann wird es irgendwie dann
erst wird dann halt sowieso gehen wir
diese diamant kiste mit eisen und die
wird dann irgendwie doppelt so viel
platz bieten
holz ist und die würden dann halt auch
dementsprechend anders aussehen ihr seht
dass diese diamant schätzt sein außer
ein bisschen blauen ja das ist auf jeden
fall die sache nummer vier ich fans
richtig cool wir haben ja damals in dem
hero hexe projekt gab es dass jeder gab
sie reisen jazz und gold und diamant ist
aber die sondern nicht im wald und das
war richtig cool und dann kann dich
gemacht was ganz lustig wäre
eine obsidian rösti man bekommt wenn man
zum beispiel um den brustpanzer zu
machen einen die abos panzer in die
mitte legt und acht ob sie die ander
umlegt sozusagen verstärkt man seinen
dia panzer mit dem obsidian die rossi
hätte dann dauerhaft zur resistenz und
explosionsschutz aber sie wäre nur um
zwei punkte stärker wie die ja sonst ist
ok also freunde sind das crafting rezept
eingeblendet man nimmt quasi einfach
irgendwie eine dia brust platte und
packt obsidian rum um dann bekommt man
diese obsidian rüstet die auch ein wenig
dunkler ist als die ganz normale diamant
ist sie also ihr seht da ich habe so ein
bisschen lila mehr gepixelt und wie hat
schon vorgelesen habe man verstärkt
damit seinen dia panzer mit diesem
obsidian und die rossi hat dauerhafte
feuer resistenz und explosionsschutz
aber sie ist nur zwei punkte stärker als
die arbeit soll zur op wer kenn dich
ganz cool wenn man diese rüstung noch
ein bisschen krasser machen könnte
ich denke aber dass es trotzdem schon zu
op wäre also das ist ja oft so liegt in
der diskussion bei dieser folge dieser
serie
das ist ok und alles aber es ist auf
jeden fall ein ganz coole sache aber da
würde ich mir auch denken dass ich schon
zu krass weil auch über eine komplette
die rüstung hat ist man mittlerweile
gegen fast alle mops irgendwie immun und
keiner kann einem irgendwie noch schaden
zufügen und dann ist man mit dieser
obsidian roussety halt irgendwie noch
explosionsschutz und feuer resistent
also das wäre schon zu ps ist auf jeden
fall ganz coole sache und danke an dich
mister butter nuss phlox das war es auch
wieder was mache ich hier immer für eine
scheiße das war es auch schon wieder mit
den kräftigen ideen heute donnerstag ja
ich glaube dass donnerstag aber ist auch
egal wenn es euch gefallen hat freunde
würde ich sagen bitte zwei mit einer
bewertung wenn ihr dann weitere folgen
von die säulen crafting idee dinge sehen
wollt weil ich es einfach cool finde mit
euch zu interagieren wie ihr seht ja
schon ich bleibe in letzter zeit viel
viel häufiger einfach in welche
kommentaren videos ein und blablabla
also wenn ihr ideen habt schreibt mir
die kommentare und dann sehen wir uns in
der nächsten folge wieder
ein konzert an darunter